So, you disliked him because his son liked him. I was skeptical
of him because he was campaigning
>> Let's go. That W that chatter. Oh, no. Is Hutch starting
to get it? Did Abdul El-Sayed somehow tell a story about his
kid [__] his bed and Hutch went, "You know what?
I'm starting to understand everything."
More fresh Hutch content.
You love to see it. The guy links the timestamp and just uh says,
"Hutch showing signs of brain activity." We're talking about
Grand Platner, some of the stuff surrounding Grand Platner. All
right, Hutch's reaction to Grand Platner being the presumptive
winner of the Democratic uh Senate race primary in Maine. Okay,
his opponent dropped out yesterday. A lot of people are celebrating.
You know, he had a commanding lead in that primary. He's got
a big lead over his opponent in the general. Things are looking
up for Platner. But, funny enough, okay, I actually there's a
little wrinkle to it. As far as blue no matter who goes, it seems
like a lot of people are coming out of the woodwork now, libs,
saying things like, "Well, actually, I just can't vote for a
guy who had a Nazi tattoo. I can't do it. I can't bring myself
to do it." Imagine that. Imagine living in a world where you
say, "Well, principally, I just can't vote for somebody who's
done this bad thing." I'm shocked so many Dems have the position
that actually getting a Nazi tattoo 10 years ago and getting
it tattooed over and never having any of those beliefs is worse
than aiding and abetting a genocide. But, here we are. >> very
freaked out by this guy. >> He's very freaked out by this
guy, all >> kind of freaked out about this whole
It does >> So, really spooky scary guy. >> very worried.
There was a lot of stuff going on. I mean, like Janet Mills evidently
just never really like fully launched a
The whole thing was >> But, now you have to think about
the reason for that, right?
There's a reason she basically didn't fully launch a campaign.
She was She was asked to do this as a favor. She didn't get very
much money coming in at first. She was not polling well right
off the Basically, like the only chance she really had was when
the Platner tattoo stuff first came out, and they had his like
his campaign manager's former campaign manager go off about it.
And realistically, she's just never
she's just a limp fish. She's like not really doing much, man.
She's like barely There's barely signs of life with Janet Mills
or her campaign. She could be doing stuff on her own. She could
be talking. She could be going places. She didn't do anything
to get any What is it? It's not free media. It's like um Oh,
there's a word for it. Earned media. She wasn't doing any earned
media at all. She like wasn't willing to try unless she got a
bunch of money from donors right off the bat. And once that didn't
materialize, I think she basically was just like, "Well, give
me money or else this guy wins." I feel like that is To me, that's
me reading between the lines, but that's how I feel about it.
>> done so haphazardly.
Uh Chuck Schumer personally intervened to try to get her to run,
but then she didn't really get like a bunch of backing from a
lot of high-profile Democrats, and so her campaign just ran out
of cash.
You know, she ran like one or two attack ads against him, but
she did not really have a lot of money on hand according to reporting
to aggressively run a campaign against him. So, you know, maybe
that's the reason why he just like dominated like he did.
Um they are going to bury this guy
in ads in campaign ads, guys. I'm not even necessarily like worried
about the pirate tattoo.
Not a Nazi tattoo.
But a pirate tattoo. I'm not even necessarily worried about the
pirate tattoo. I'm more worried about the old Reddit posts that
are kind of like
misogynistic.
I'm worried about how
Does anybody have this Reddit post? Can I see this Reddit post
where he says like that what Are we going to discuss this woman's
behavior when she got or something? Can I see this Reddit post?
Cuz I don't know what it is. I don't know exactly what he was
saying. I feel
in terms of gender sensitivity,
if we're
it's definitely not a moral position. Hutch is just worried that
the Republicans are going to capitalize, guys. It's not not a
moral aversion to him making those comments, obviously.
Right? It It just has to be he's worried about the attack ads.
>> Women voters in Maine
who are kind of the backbone, like the women voters are kind
of the backbone of the Democratic Party. I'm worried about how
they're going to react to some of his older Reddit posts, like
victim-blaming women and and stuff like that. Um I mean, the
pirate tattoo is not great, but I think that might honestly hurt
him hurt him more. The uh the more problematic misogynistic posts,
the the the victim-blaming posts.
>> What is different about Platner versus Mark Robinson
in New North Carolina, and why does Platner work?
Um I think
>> I mean, the obvious difference there, that's a stupid
question. The obvious difference is Mark Robinson goes, "I'm
a Nazi. I'M A BLACK NAZI. I WANT SLAVES." And Grant Platner's
like, "I'm not a Nazi at all. I'm just trying to explain to you
guys like how somebody might have a tattoo like this without
realizing it or or some of the reasons people might have tattoos
that seem insensitive, but it doesn't mean that within the culture."
Right? Do you Do we understand the difference between these two
things? Mark Robinson, former lieutenant governor in Was it South
Carolina, I think? Right, the guy who had the He was the black
Nazi guy. His DMs or his his former Reddit posts got leaked.
Like obviously that guy was a racist and was describing or or
acting out or talking about his racist thoughts in public. Grant
Platner was not a racist. Grant Platner Nobody really accused
Grant Platner of being racist outside of the black people don't
tip thing, which I'm going to be honest,
I'm going to let that go. That's like I I know that's big of
me being white and all, but I'm going to let that one go, okay?
>> I think like uh the first time I saw this guy's ad before
we knew anything about his old Reddit posts and tattoos and stuff
like that. I immediately thought like, oh, this is a really interesting
candidate.
He's very masculine-coded,
was pushing a kind of light populism in the beginning. Well,
I guess it wasn't all that light. But I I knew that we were kind
of heading into a populist cycle, and so when I saw his campaign
ad, I just thought like, oh, this guy has a potential to connect
with, I think, a lot of voters, and um I thought he was interesting
right away.
>> Yeah, I He hasn't really described He said he was like
spooky, there's like something scary, and then he just says like,
oh, well, I don't know if he's going to do well with the attack
ads against him. He hasn't described I think what he's talking
about is this guy has basically outlined that he thinks a paradigm
shift is required. Right? Platner has talked about how, well,
I don't necessarily think the system can be fixed through incremental
means, I think there is something of a revolution that needs
to happen to fix things. Is he even that populist? Yes, he is.
You just got to listen to some of the longer-form interviews,
Missy. Like he is he is talking about an upheaval of the system
from an economic
And it is populist in nature. It is saying, we don't have I think
he said that without democracy in the economy, without a democratic
like without some sort of democratic distribution of the of the
economic
output of the country, there can be no true democracy. There's
no political democracy without an economic democracy, right?
That's his thoughts. Now, that's verging on something like communism,
maybe, but I think he's basically just saying that a wealth redistribution
of some kind is required that basically, as long as you have
massive concentrations of wealth, the idea of political power,
your vote won't be worth as much. There can be manipulations
that there will be manipulations using people's wealth that allows
them to just control massive amounts of people and get their
will
Which is not wrong. It's obviously correct. He's just been talking
about it. He He talks about it quite specifically. We watched
the John Yeah, the John Stewart I was going to say John Daly.
No, not the golfer. The Daily Show host, former Daily Show host,
John Stewart, interviewed him, and he talked about this at length.
>> But I'm I am worried. I am worried about this race a
lot. I'm very very worried.
Um, you have to understand when when Susan Collin Collins won
her last race, I think it was in 2020 and she outperformed her
polls guys by double
I don't think people remember. I don't think most people remember
how crazy that was.
Her opponent was running double digits ahead of her in the polls
and Susan Collins still managed to win.
So I I think you do need generally
>> Susan Collins sounds frail. Like I I I said this yesterday.
I could hear her speak. That quaver in her voice no longer has
a charm to it. It sounds like old age.
I don't think vote I don't think voters are going to hear it
the same way this time around, man. Also, in general
it is a I don't know if it's like a more I I tend to agree with
Hassan in the framing that it's a more revolutionary time. Like
people feel very very hard done by.
The idea that you're a 20-year incumbent has to work against
you massively right now. If you are a 20-year incumbent and everything's
gone in the direction it's gone, people are pissed.
I feel like that is probably not even showing yet, but as you
hear her saying that like as she has to defend her record, defend
what's going on in the country, defend her advocacy for certain
things, it's almost impossible to be a 20-year incumbent win
right now. I feel like it's very difficult.
>> 30-year? 30-year incumbent, sorry. >> like Collins.
I think you do need a really strong candidate.
And even though this guy is pulling ahead of her right now, it's
like the polls I think head-to-head with him versus Collins are
anywhere from like plus six to plus 10 for
But this is before the avalanche of campaign ads that are going
to flood the airwaves in Maine. This is before >> Honestly,
paid for media is like very ineffective right now. And I really
don't think that the ads that they can take out against this
guy are going to work. They're like individual anecdotes about
that he said that really don't come through in any of his rhetoric
at all. And like a lot of it is I was a military guy, I have
a a different view of things now that I've been out for a while,
right?
I actually don't know if it's going to be all that effective.
My personal thought. I'll hit play.
he's been scrutinized to the extent that he will be. He's had
some attention on him during this primary, but it's it's going
to ratchet way the [__] up. Like more and more people
in this country are going to know about this guy
in the coming weeks and months. And boy does he have a lot of
vulnerabilities. The tats didn't hurt Hegseth.
Well, you know, Hegseth that was a confirmation post. Like Hegseth
wasn't running running an election, you know.
This guy freaks
>> Dude, I don't think I again, I think superficials Does
superficial stuff like this work anymore in the era of Trump?
I don't know I like it maybe it works at the margins.
But I feel like your rhetoric
far and away outdoes
anything that can like be brought up like a little comment on
Twitter or something from your past.
I feel like it it's outstrips it massively. Like your rhetoric,
the things you say, and this guy is very good at messaging. The
things you say matter way more than your like random tweet from
10 years ago, your random Reddit post from 10 years ago. I just
don't believe it's going to actually be that consequential.
populism just generally freaks me out. And so, I'm a little freaked
out at the Michigan race as well. >> Well, inshallah.
Dude, dude.
Wait, what? Did she get freaked out by >> She asked him,
do you think that the Democrats are actually going to flip the
Senate? So.
Uh there's another thing from this in a little bit here. There's
another
blurb from this we're going to watch. I still don't He said populism.
Dude, if he listens, if Hutch listens to some long-form stuff
with Platner, he's going to lose his mind. Cuz trust me, when
I when I listen to
it basically says he's like a little more extreme than Bernie
would be, I would imagine.
I don't even know if I've heard Hasan say that. Like, basically
Platner very heavily leans into we need a revolution in this
country. We need like an economic revolution in this country.
just the ways he talks about power and stuff, I feel like it's
going to weird Hutch out massively.
So, maybe we'll go back watch a little bit more of that interview
after. Here's the second timestamp. This is just on This is Hutch
talking to or about Sorry, it's Hutch talking about El Sayed.
Here we go. >> You've been in New York for a little bit,
and you had to have residency in Michigan for 4 years. So, what
did you learn from that loss? >> Honestly, it's not about
me. It really is about the the people that I want to serve. And
I think in a lot of ways it was my first >> What did you
learn from that loss? Oh god, please listen.
I will be less skeptical of this person
if he gives an honest answer to that question without blaming
external forces, okay?
All you got to do All you All you got to do like just give me
something that your campaign maybe got wrong or could have could
have done better.
Can't be that difficult, right?
>> Do politicians do this?
I feel like Hutch is confusing El Sayed for a pundit. Pundits
do this. Pundits will make excuses.
No, you should never be a politician making excuses. It is a
It is always a bad look to make excuses and talk about how you
were hard done by when realistically all you have to say, if
you want to run again, is I didn't get my message out there well
enough. There were things I could have done better. There are
things I need to do better, and I will be better the next time.
That's what you say, right? You don't blame other people, you
don't blame anything else, right? You say as a politician, you
say it's on me. I didn't do well enough. There are things I could
have done better. I am going to learn things for next time. At
least that's my my thought. That's how I conceive of it. Like
it doesn't look good when you complain about like APAC spending
or something as a politician. Looks real >> Right. Just
I'm running for office. >> Unless you're Trump. Yeah, unless
you're Trump and you've got like this babying coalition of cultists
who will who will go, "Oh my god, what a victim. Oh, you're okay,
Trump."
>> I was 32, never run for office before, right? I had
bad advice from a former president who told me I should run for
office at my college graduation and >> Bill Clinton. >> You
know, I said I'll go big or go home. Yeah, I I went big and and
then and then I went home. But like I
>> of ways I I think I missed the point in that race. >> What
do you mean? >> Because I wanted everybody to agree with
me on the critique.
Right? And and and at the end of the day, I don't need everybody
to agree with me on the critique. I need them to agree with me
on the solution. And then I took it really personally as like
a referendum on me and my work, and it's not. Your job, this
is why I keep going back to this point. I'm not running against
anybody. I'm running for the people of the state of Michigan.
>> There it is. There it is. I Here are the mistakes I
made. Here's like what I [__] up. Here's how I will
be better next time. Yep. Easy peasy. >> job every day
is to build a stronger, deeper relationship where they know who
I am, warts and all. And there's >> You know what?
I kind of like that answer.
You know what?
He didn't do the thing. He didn't do the thing where he blamed
it on uh rigged elections and you know >> And I really
don't know. Do politicians do that? I really think like Bernie
tried to avoid this as much as possible, right?
Bernie tried very hard to avoid blaming like almost anything.
He would say he would talk about how his his camp his campaign
failed. He'd let surrogates say like that. But man, it doesn't
sound good when you're a politician, you're just making excuses,
so. >> The donors and you know, that that he actually sounded
like there was some accountability in it. >> I'm not counting
Trump. Trump is not when I talk about politicians, I'm not talking
about Trump, ever.
Trump plays by different rules and he gets like different voters
and it's ridiculous, but it can't be emulated. It doesn't work
for anybody. Nobody else can do what Trump does. Nobody can act
like a total
like Trump does and have it work for them. I don't know what
the magic is there. I don't know how he managed it, but nobody
else can be a whiny baby and just get their way every single
time. >> And they're right. >> There's going to be
people who say, you know, I I I know who he is and I don't like
him. That's okay. But I want the folks to know who I am and what
I'm going to fight for and every day I serve in the US Senate.
They're like, yeah, this is what Abdul said he was going to fight
for. This is what Abdul is fighting for and this is what Abdul
is winning and I know what I get with him and so that's I think
the biggest um learning. The other thing that's changed is like
I had kids. >> Yeah, your wife was pregnant during the
campaign, right? >> She She was. I was I mean we we gave
birth to our first Well, she gave birth to our first kid um uh
on the campaign trail and it was um it was a real moment for
me, but I'll be honest, like there's something about the moment
that your kid comes to your bed in the middle of the night and
like they're kicking you in the face, everything. Then they soil
your bed. And then you have to wake up, clean them, clean your
bed.
weird weird direction for this. >> yourself. And the whole
time all you're worried about is how are you doing? Are you okay?
Are you going to get back to sleep? And I think it's a really
important metaphor because it teaches you a lot of patience with
things. At the end of the day, like that's a deeply unfair situation.
Somebody comes to your bed, soils your bed and you're trying
to clean them up and make them happy, but >> But they're
still your kid. >> They're still your kid and you love
them and you want them you want them to feel okay about the whole
>> You know? >> I feel like I feel like Hutch is
the kind of guy this works on. I I literally hate stories like
this when I'm listening to politicians talk. I understand the
need to do it, but for me personally, I hate anecdotes like this.
It was why I hated listening to Liz Warren talk on the campaign
trail. I despise cuz she always had some stupid story about a
person she met in a story she heard to basically show one of
her proposals. And I'm like, "Dude, this doesn't make you sound
human to me. Makes you sound like you don't have She just did
it all the time. Every time was cut to some stupid anecdote the
counterpoints like method of governance or the counterpoints
method of campaigning. I can't handle it. I'm sure Hutch is the
kind of guy it works on >> You know what, guys? I have
not spent a lot of time like actually looking into
I just see who he hangs out with and that makes me uh
some questions pop into my mind, but I got to be honest with
you. I find him a little charming. >> whole thing. And
similarly, as a public servant, your job is always to serve the
public. And no matter what happens, you
Auditing himself as cattle? A little bit. I think
if anything, when I when I try to evaluate politics, I try not
to let this impulse for like a bias against anecdotes get me
too much cuz I think I think a lot of people do like stories
like that if you can deliver them well.
Like I think that's why Joe Biden is Joe Biden's very good at
it. Joe Biden's good at being charming. You listen to old old
stories like the corn pop one. Joe Biden's pretty good at being
charming. Most people are not.
All right. So I try I think I'm probably and maybe you guys too.
I I'm probably in the wrong direction on this versus the public.
So I try not to get too too crinched out about this stuff
>> You got to focus on how can I make sure that you got
the things you need at the end of the day. It's not about me.
>> Who's the kid in that
It's like his idea of fairness comes from his kid soiling the
bed and him thinking, "This is really unfair."
It's a little It's a little goofy. A little goofy to me. >> analogy.
Well, it's not it's not the the point of kids. It's about what
you do out of out of an unqualified love of somebody. Right?
You love your kids unqualifiedly. It doesn't matter what they
do, you will always love them and try to comfort them and try
to give them the best that they deserve. And I think as a public
servant, you have to commit yourself to an unqualified kind of
unconditional love for the people you serve, where you're constantly
focused on them regardless of what some folks who you serve are
going to say about you. There are going to be people in
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
He might have pulled it back with the last part. He might have
pulled it back. It might be a good story now. I'm sorry. It might
actually be a good story now when he says like even cuz it's
always good to remind people that yeah, you're trying to run
and do better for everybody. That like even if you don't like
me, even if you don't like what I run on or what I stand for,
I'm still going to take care of you. It doesn't matter if you
come and [__] my bed. I'm a little annoyed, but you
know what?
I'm still going to take care of it. Cuz I'm I'm the dad in this
situation. That that made it better, all right. >> they
are, who hate my guts. And it has nothing to do with anything
I said or did. It has everything to do with my background and
and and >> So you disliked him because his son liked him.
I was skeptical of him because he was campaigning
>> Let's go. That W that chatter. Oh, no. He He I just
said that. I just said that. I just don't like I don't like the
people this guy hangs around with. >> with his son, which
I think reflects just poor judgment.
>> Except he started campaigning with his son, he immediately
jumped in massively in the polls. So does it reflect poor judgment
or maybe you're not judging the situation from an unbiased place?
Which one do you think? Third place when he started campaigning
with his son. First place now.
>> You know, listening to him speak and I don't like the
answers that he's giving and he strikes a good tone and you know,
seems like a kind of impressive guy. >> what I mean about
what this country is. And you know what I want them to say after
six years of my service? I want them to be like, "Man, that guy
was the best senator Michigan ever could have. I still hate him.
I still hate him. But, you know what? Like, when I called his
office, they answered back. They gave me real answers. And when
I needed something, they were there for me. That's what public
service is." >> These are just You know, these are very
smooth, polished answers. I think this kind of messaging
really connects with voters.
Um I do think right now, guys, we're at a We're at a really interesting
I don't even know what that word means.
>> Which really only goes further to show why you shouldn't
campaign with El-Sayed. Okay.
this guy's name was not in the media. Barely anybody knew who
this guy was.
Like, nobody was talking about Well, some people were talking
about it, but this race was not getting anywhere near the traction
it's getting now. Right? Like, it starts getting picked up in
the media because when when El-Hassan went to go campaign with
El-Sayed, a bunch of people, including our friend Oh, Unf America,
Z. Z to the Hill. Okay? Everybody's like, "Well, El-Hassan announced
a campaign thing here? Oh, we're going to go encounter We're
going to go counter table there. We're going to go do a table
against
Like, okay. Uh weird. And then Third Way article comes out. They
get quotes from McMorrow talking about how El-Hassan is racist,
Stevens saying El-Hassan is racist and anti-Semitic. Right?
All this stuff, and it blows it up. It blows that race up, puts
El-Sayed in the limelight, and he's a good speaker. So, when
he gets put in the limelight, he changes hearts and minds.
It's a perfect strategy. Fantastic judgment. Thank you, Mr. El-Sayed,
for having fantastic judgment.
>> We're in a really interesting juncture.
where there are millions of people in this country that voted
for Donald Trump that regret their vote.
a lot of these people are very turned
by the Democratic Party as much as they regret their vote and
as much as they're >> Uh-oh. Is Hutch Uh-oh.
Hutch is
Is Hutch starting to get it? Did Did Abdul El-Sayed somehow tell
a story about his kid [__] his bed and Hutch went,
"You know what? I think I understand every I'm I'm starting to
understand everything."
>> disgusted and disappointed with the current administration.
They still are extremely apprehensive and wary about supporting
Democrats. Like the Democratic Party brand is utter trash right
now.
And so, you know, this kind of language I think is smart
to to you know, he he he's
There's like some overlap with populism.
Oh, it feels good. It feels good. Starting to see a pattern here.
Hutch's mind lights up whenever poop is involved. Hmm.
Very interesting and disturbing pattern that we're noticing here.
My goodness.
I I see this guy in chat, "But we're winning. What do you mean
our our brand is bad? We're winning right now. We won all these
races, man. Don't you remember all the stuff you've been saying?
All the trash you've been filling my brain with, Hutch? Don't
you remember any of that? Oh my god."
>> hasn't been sort of like not being non-partisan or less
partisan.
But I think like the less partisan
most likely to succeed in converting back like the voters that
we've lost in recent years.
And so, I I I think this kind of messaging is like really especially
good for like a swing state like Michigan that actually voted
for Donald Trump in the last election. We do a lot of like
rhetoric talking about MAGA and and their base and their voters
and the people, you know, we we do a lot of like moral judgments
of people that voted for Donald Trump in 2024.
But, if you're a politician that's running for a contested seat
in, you know, a state that voted for Donald Trump, you know,
you're not going to see that kind of scorched earth rhetoric.
You're going to You're going to hear much more like, inviting
rhetoric.
That's why we're seeing it in places like Texas. That's why we're
seeing it in places like Maine. Like, there's a there's a kind
of pattern emerging emerging. Even Mondaire Jones to a certain
extent, you know, did this and it makes me kind of like
angry sometimes listening to it because I am angry at people
>> Oh boy. Oh boy. Dude, he just did this whole set of
reactions to me saying I was a total [__] for speaking
the way I was. Let's go. I won. I'm declaring victory, okay?
I I'm sorry.
There was so much time where he just had to listen to me without
having like a filter there. I just totally won. I'm I'm calling
it. We declare victory >> voted for Donald Trump in 2024
and I do think that they deserve like some condemnation, right?
But, it's But, I'm I'm I'm I'm excited to see politicians using
this kind of rhetoric that's like less partisan, explicitly less
partisan because I think that is going to be the winning strategy
in the >> It's almost like running on MAGA's really bad,
Trump's really bad is not so good and running on your own vision,
your idea of what's good. Saying, "Hey, this is my plan. This
is the thing I believe in." Right? Not, "Oh my god, it's Dude,
we're breaking through. Let's >> next few years. >> Mitch
is about to start thinking about the world he wants. What world
do I want to live in? What's the world What's the What's like
my nirvana? >> years. You're just going to see a lot of
It's not an accident that they're they're they're all using language
like this, okay?
They're all, you know, talking to their pollsters and their pollsters
are showing them the numbers and their poll the pollsters are
telling them like if you if you want to win this race, you necessarily
have to persuade some people that voted for Donald Trump in 2024.
And the more of them that you persuade, the higher your chances
of winning are.
>> on his pill. Well, no, it's a it's a C it's a chair
with the bottom cut out of it that he can lie under. That's his
Nirvana with Soy Pill, of course, sitting in the chair. That's
his Nirvana, obviously. But I mean for the country, Berin, not
his personal >> All right. And so, you know, all of them
are using this kind of rhetoric. You're not really seeing a lot
of like sports
>> I'll try to chill. >> rhetoric. You're seeing
you're hearing this kind of stuff.
Populism is good in swing states now. Well, listen, populism
I think is just bad, but
I think it's necessary. >> He's like,
"Ah, he's trying to reconcile. He's got two wolves, okay? They're
fighting right now. He's trying to reconcile it. How do I Populism
is always bad, but like everybody needs to hear a populist message.
And Democrats ARE DOING REALLY WELL, but everyone hates the Democrats.
But like we're winning elections, but also this guy's climbing
in the poll. It's it's all over the place. It
It's very cool.
I think populism is
a tool, okay?
Unfortunately,
I will say by and large populism seems to be used by people who
are trying to manipulate you into voting for you then, like and
trying to get you on their side with no real intention to help
because people are psychos, okay? That has been how populism
has been used historically, but it doesn't have to be used that
way. It It you can deliver a message and mean it. Right? And
it's just like, "Hey, some of you guys need to understand how
to speak in a way." And Al Sayed can do it. Mondani can do it.
You need to understand how to speak in a way that like the average
person can hear you and hear like how much you want to help them.
Cuz that's the problem is when you only talk in policies, when
you only talk in this highfalutin language, they don't understand
you. They think you're like trying to control them or something,
okay? You just need to understand how to communicate your ideas.
And this populist lens, this populist bend is how you do it.
>> necessary right now. It doesn't need to be like full
brain rot populism,
but like some populism
framing, like some populist rhetoric,
I think is like a necessary evil right now. Cuz it is the thing
that is like It is the thing that's connecting with voters, and
there's just no fighting it. So, even though I personally think
that populism is dumb and it makes everybody >> Populism
in this case is being like, I care about everybody, by the way.
That's the populism we're engaging in. The populism is, I care
about people. I like people. I made mistakes. I want to be better.
I love my district. I love my state. I want all these people
to love me, too. I want to be the best senator that's ever come
from here. That's apparently the populism he's engaging in right
now. I'm not saying he's not a populist. I'm sure he's got some
economic populist ideas. But in terms of this conversation, the
things that's changed The thing that is The thing that has changed
is he just sounds like a human being. We should We also shouldn't
confuse sounding like a human being for being populist.
They're not necessarily the same thing. They tend to overlap,
right? But that's I don't think El Sayed's been doing particularly
populist messaging right now. He's basically just going, like,
I want to take care of these people. I like these people. I like
these Michiganders, okay? These Michiganders, these Michigan
people, I love them. I want to take care of them. Even if they
hate me, I want to take care of them. That's not populism, bro.
That's being a
I don't mind hearing it because I understand that it I just I
just want I just want these politicians I just want these Democrats
to run the kind of campaigns that that are going to maximize
the chance chances of winning.
And then >> They are called Michiganders, okay? I I Michiganders?
Michiganders?
>> when we do win, when we finally do win a trifecta again,
which I think is chances are very good right now of another trifecta
in 2028 with just the way things are going,
I just want them to do what they have to do to win and then I
want them to
just like do sh- like just get in there and start doing Day one,
filibuster, gone. Just get rid of the filibuster day one. Vote
to change the Senate rules and just get rid of that thing and
then just start Okay. All right. I think that's probably all
we need from this. Man, I need to go I need to go do a victory
lap by the way on the other thing. Okay. After watching some
of the responses on Twitter, I was just totally correct on this.
Everything I said about hey, blue no matter who means you guys
agree to follow their frame and you guys will get over if you
win. And then Platner Mills drops out unexpectedly and we get
an answer way sooner than we expected and a ton of people like
no, I can't do it. I can't vote for this guy. I can't I can't
recommend this guy. So many people did it. >> Her endorsements
could flip last minute. Every single one of those coin flips
that seem like a coin flip scenario is going to go against you
and you're going to get destroyed by a by them, okay? You're
going to lose because of them. And just just get ready cuz not
only that, but if you win these primaries, get ready for the
Hutch types, okay? Whether I'm not sure if Hutch misspoke or
what happened there. But with the Hutch types again, >> I
did.
>> get ready in November
for these people to work against you. The way they worked against
Mumdani, okay? Get ready for that. It's going to
That's why you got to be overwhelming. Cuz you you aren't going
to get >> This is kind of self-defeating logic because
I definitely did not work against Mumdani. >> Blue no matter
who. Blue Now you're a super supporter of the people not endorsing
Mumdani even though somebody from the primary the Dem primary
is running against him. You were like oh no, I sort of understand
why they're not >> who is them trying to break you into
following whatever they want.
And I but at the same time, you should vote for Democrats over
Republicans especially until the Republican Party has some major
schism or change. The reaction is so good. The reaction is so
good, man.
Now he actually misunderstands it at first, but we'll see once
he gets his people to watch with him if he understands it after
actually doing it.
Can we just listen to that? Everybody listen, I I need everyone
to focus up.
>> I just want to point out again, that point is unequivocally
true. We just watched it happen. Platner won and a bunch of people,
a bunch of the blue no matter who's, we can't have a say in the
coalition types, all came out went, "He has a Nazi tattoo. I'll
never vote for somebody who had a Nazi tattoo. It just shows
bad judgment. But you have to vote for Kamala even though she
let a genocide happen, okay? Even though she didn't say anything,
she didn't want to make any changes."
Totally incoherent.
These people just want you to follow what they're saying, all
right? They're not trying to make an argument, they're not trying
to actually sincerely commit to a principle. They're incoherent.
Don't worry about it. That's why you got to be overwhelming at
the polls, okay? >> Hey, I need you guys to focus up. Where
the lurkers at? >> Now he asks for Now he asks for his
chatters to come and participate. >> We need to just listen
to what he just said because that feels like a crazy massive
contradiction what he just said. >> They worked against
Okay? Get ready for that. It's going to happen.
That's why you got to be overwhelming. Cuz you you aren't going
to get blue no matter who. Blue no matter who is them trying
to break you into following whatever they want. >> Blue
no Blue no matter who
is them trying to break you.
>> No matter what you want? Is that what he said? Hold
on. That >> It's going to happen.
It's not blue no matter who, it's you need to commit to doing
what I want you to do if you lose. That's what it is. It's not
actually blue no matter who. You need to commit to doing if you
lose, but if I lose, well, I'm going to with you. I'm going to
I'm going to totally [__] with you. That's why you
got to be overwhelming. Cuz you you aren't going to get blue
no matter who. Blue no matter who is them trying to break you
into following whatever they want. >> Blue no matter who
is them trying to break you into following whatever they want.
Dot dot dot. And then he immediately follows it up with
>> And I but at the same time, you should vote for Democrats
over Republicans, especially until the Republican Party has some
major schism or change. Republicans are evil. But, the blue no
my good sir.
>> You have just stumbled upon the exceedingly
simple logic of blue no matter who.
>> To be honest, for me for me personally
I'm sitting here and I'm like, "Okay, now that Hutch is saying
blue no matter who like this." And he's Listen to my arguments
and he's like, "No, no, no, it has to be blue no matter who."
He's got to be going after people on Twitter, right? Anybody
who's going after the Platner tattoo, he's got to be [__]
on those people, RIGHT? LIKE JOSIAH'S. JOSIAH I can believe cuz
Josiah's out here absolutely [__] down the throat
of any person
at all who is remotely going, "Well, I don't know if I can vote
for this guy." He's destroying them. He's going hard on them.
He doesn't want to hear from any of these people, right? Not
a contradiction, but you sound conservative. Why do I sound conservative?
When I'm saying that you have to be overwhelmingly as a leftist,
you have to actually win in the polls. How's that conservative?
What part of that is conservative?
>> That's why we say blue no matter who.
Because the Republicans are genuinely that bad.
They are so
bad. We are so past the point where it's acceptable to elect
even a single
>> But, my point was that you will not actually you will
not actually do this this thing. Or a lot of people who watch
you won't actually do this thing. That they don't have a sincere
commitment to >> at any level of government. And it wasn't
always like that, to be honest with you. It wasn't always like
that. The stakes were not always this high
in terms of uh Democrat winning a race versus a Republican winning.
>> Well, hold on. I'm basically saying that I'm not I'm
not outlawing the entire other side of your country, right? I
don't know like you've Obviously, there's something that
and I don't I'm not an American, so I didn't do American history.
You guys had something called the Southern Strategy and then
the parties flipped basically their their platforms.
Like the the Democrats were the southern part of the country
and a lot more conservative and then they flipped, right? I'm
basically leaving allowance for that. I'm not saying it's like
totally okay. I'm saying essentially there should be no consideration
on voting ever for the other party until things change massively.
I'm assuming when the Trump coalition breaks, when the Republicans
break, they'll have there'll be some kind of realignment,
That's all. >> winning a race. The whole party
the whole Republican party has become so compromised
that is genuinely dangerous.
Therefore, you should vote for the
>> Like in terms of my politics, I've never been conservative
enough in any dimension, not economically, not conservatively,
to have ever If I lived in the States, I would never vote Republican
at any point in my life when I could vote. Like I would have
always been a Democrat voter. I could vote conservative in some
places in Canada, but I could never go to the States and vote
for Republicans ever. If that's what you're thinking here, like
I have I've like some Essentially,
I'd maybe be like socially centrist and economically left in
America.
>> On the top of the ticket and every Democrat down ballot.
On every election that you could possibly vote in. That is the
logic of blue no matter who. It's
we want to pound the electorate into submission so they don't
ask for more >> Uh yes, it is.
>> It's not that. It isn't that. We can see Democrats at
the state
you're probably just confusing rhetoric for worldview, Missy.
Like when I talk about how immigration needs to freeze because
that's a very easy issue and there's a populist like leftist
economic angle to it and
like it's a humanist worldview. It's like and if you want to
add more social services, then adding a bunch of people like
allowing more open flow over the borders is probably not a good
idea. I feel like these are all logical points
that I I don't even really think are They're very difficult to
debate against, in my opinion. Like basically any plan that's
going to cause like or or going to include mass social program
creation, you're going to want to know what the population is.
You're going to want to know You're going to want to have control.
I'm not saying you can't have immigration. I'm not even saying
you have to cut immigration. The border should be controlled
so you can actually know who's coming in and out.
>> state level all over the country that are responding
to the bases' desires, like actually delivering
a legislative agenda that is that responds to what they're asking
for. We are seeing that aggressively
happening in Virginia right now. Spanberger is like like These
bills that >> Yeah, Hutch Hutch really missed the point.
I just wanted it on the record that he was wrong, okay? He was
wrong even though he missed the point, he was also wrong. Unless
he wants to go and start on all these same people that Josiah
on, spend his time doing that, cuz obviously he was so that leftists,
right? for any hint at oh well, we don't want to vote Kamala.
She was She isn't doing enough. Every single one of these people,
hold on. I'm going to go to Hutch's Twitter right now, okay?
Hutchinson. How much time is he spend spending on the liberals
who don't want to vote for Platinor? We got any of that?
Um This is just really embarrassing. If you want to run on abolishing
ICE, make your pitch. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Uh yep. Nope.
I don't see it. Nope. It's just not happening, right? Well, hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. We might have replies. Maybe we've got
replies.
Replies? Replies? We've got replies?
not not seeing anything about Platinor yet. Almost deport in
chief, okay.
Uh do we retweet this? Maybe we retweet
Ah, I CAN'T I CAN'T. AH, I DUDE.
super don't respect Soy Pill's
testicular fortitude or spine, but I absolutely hate
YouTubers getting their videos demonetized or having their videos
within any way. I will retweet. God damn it. It's just a principle
thing, okay, guys? It's just a principle thing. YouTubers get
their
I feel like I hate to see it. I hate to see it every time, even
if it's somebody I feel like is a spineless loser. I came up
for Tactical Templar, and let's be honest, Soy Pill's nowhere
near as bad as Tactical Templar, okay?
I retweeted this Tactical Templar [__]
Yeah, no no posts going after the no posts, zero posts. Zero
posts going after the people who are basically saying they won't
vote Platner. And I know people in Hutch's audience are doing
it cuz I've seen those people chat in Hutch's audience
Very cool, very interesting. You think he'd spend a little time,
right? Just a little time. I'm not saying all the time, just
a little time, man. I'll be in Portland tomorrow with Grant Vermain
to kick off his campaign to retire Susan Collins. Let's go win
this thing. So disappointing. You betrayed the people who stood
up for your for you and your family, especially your wonderful
son, Gus. Oh, this is the thing Grant Platner said about somebody
like 2 weeks ago.
Grant Platner said So, now
I've been around Oh, Soy Pill went on Destiny's stream and did
a whole minstrel show about how he gets DM'd by anti-fans and
then basically let Destiny try to tie that to me with his audience,
even though he doesn't believe that, and then he wouldn't correct
he obviously hasn't corrected it on any similar size platform
in any way. So, to me, when you go and do that despite not really
believing that, when you let that impression be made, you're
a spineless
So, Soy Pill totally spineless, but what can you do? What can
you do?
It's fine.